Upgrade your audio. If you're making content,
you need to make sure your audio is crisp.
Let me show you what it's like without a microphone.
And then I'm gonna plug it in.
Now we can see the difference.
Sometimes it's so powerful,
I have to hold it kind of far away.
Otherwise it's, like,
really loud. It's a really powerful microphone.
And let me show you how far I can go and it still works.
I'm walking.
I'm walking. I know you can still hear me.
I'm walking,
still going. I'm way,
way out here, and I'm super far from my phone,
but you can hear me because of the microphone.
So if you wanna upgrade your content creation,
upgrade your audio. It's linked right here if you want one.